new signal to the West Russia just
released video of this test launch of a
new intercontinental ballistic missile
called Satan - by NATO it's capable of
carrying 10 to 15 nuclear warheads this
was the second test of the missile since
December in Moscow the American
ambassador to Russia's protesting the
country's one-for-one response and the
expulsion of diplomats of the poisoning
of a former Russian spy
Russia has ordered 60 US embassy staff
out of the country and will close the
American consulate in state Petersburg
that follows the u.s. expulsion of 60
Russians part of a worldwide effort to
condemn the Kremlin for the nerve agent
attack on Sara Gates Crete Paul and his
daughter in England Charlie d'Agata is
in Moscow charlie good morning good
morning well the Kremlin this morning
said they weren't the ones to initiate a
diplomatic war they were forced to take
retaliatory steps in response to what
they called hostile illegal actions by
Washington the Kremlin has so far left
little room for compromise Vladimir
Putin has given those sixty US diplomats
a week to pack their bags and get out
the retaliation exceeded tit-for-tat
shutting down the US consulate in Saint
Petersburg is a much bigger deal than
closing the Russian consulate in Seattle
it's not only far larger it was the
first u.s. mission opened here the nerve
agent attack against a former Russian
spy turned the streets of Salisbury
England into a toxic crime scene that
has since triggered the worst diplomatic
crisis since the Cold War President
Trump avoided any mention of the
poisoning when he congratulated
President Putin on his election victory
which made the hardline international
reaction more surprising there's been
enough there to not only convince the
United States but about 25 other
countries that have taken similar
actions that there's enough evidence to
believe that the Russian state was
behind this action in Salisbury actually
28 countries in all that have expelled
more than 150 Russian diplomats since
the attack the Russians vehemently deny
any involvement and insist the back
is nothing more than a Washington
orchestrated bullying campaign over its
allies you don't read that there's a
level distrust against notion I think
that this is what what is the main goal
of the United States and Great Britain
to make Russia be regarded on the world
stage in the national stage like you
know a hooligan there's some good news
to report about Yulia scrip all the
daughter the poison spiders say her
condition is improving but that too is
an issue the Russians are demanding that
the British government allow them to see
her saying she is a Russian citizen Nora
all right Charlie d'Agata in Moscow
thank you